やあみんなこれはHiFiレビューからアンドリューです
そしてこれは次のフラッグシップ
キラーですフォニックス35zにこんにちはと言います
今これは
大きなものですそして私は
フォニックス35Zの変更をあなたが対話する方法だけでなく報告することを嬉しく思い
ます お使いの携帯電話では、ソーシャル
メディア全体として35 Zはフリップ
フォンであり、この時点で、
クールなガラスのタッチスクリーンからクランプ、
プラスチックのナンバーパック
に移行することは、Charminを非常に柔らかく投げ、
Costcoの1枚の紙やすりに戻すよう
なものです。 また、BAE
との戦闘などの基本的なことでも摩擦熱傷を引き起こす可能性
が非常に高いため、存在しないキーを探しているこのデバイス
でウォーターテンプルのフラッシュバックが発生し
ます。
これが35Zの優れ
た点です。 サボテンの
ような取り扱いのため、デバイス内で自分の間にできるだけ多くのスペースを置くことが保証されています。
これ
により、
モーフィアス
が35と呼んでいるイーズナンバーパッドは櫛のようなもので、膨大な時間を効果的に解放します。
フォニックス35Zでデジタルライフからあなたを強制的に追い出す
Facebookの代わりに
元ガールフレンドをストーカーしているあなたは実際
にファームビルで耕す代わりに元ガールフレンドをストーカーしている
ベイライナーカプリから引っ張られている間にフロントサイド360を指している
ので、この中身は別の大きなものです
が、幸いなことにフォニックスはこの部門で宿題をすることができませんでし
た。35cはスナップドラゴンプライ801を使用しています。これ
はプレマルチタスクテクノロジーです。
つまり、
時代遅れであり、何よりも機能
がないため、これを鉄製のブーツの取り扱いと組み合わせる
と、ゾラのチュニックケースがない水中迷路の底
にいて、iphoneや銀河と同じように
常に2人です
一方、
私が
35を所有していた1年半は、ジェイクとアミールのマラソンから離れて、スターを
探している人のためにインターネットにアクセスできたのは2回だけです。
これはキラー機能であり、次の電話の購入を検討するとき
に見逃してはならないものであり
、
スナップやスワイプができないことを知った後、ほとんどの
人があなたに連絡することを諦めます
ウェイクボードの練習のためにさらに30分ブームします
35Zは、すべての表面的な関係の結びつきを効果的に切断する社会的な忍者のようなもの
です。
私の偉大な叔母マーガレット以外の誰か
が実際に私に連絡してくれる
ので、時間の節約を本当に楽しみにしてい
ます。これがあなたが待ち望んで
いた
ことです。画面上のメニューに気付くと、35Zekeamauraはどのように積み重なっていきますか。
はかなり標準的な5メガピクセルを示しています
が、これらのテスト
画像
から判断すると、実際の解像度は
、5番目に作成した紙の古いペリスコープとほぼ同等の露出でゲームボーイカラーの解像度に近いと思います
フィルターに関しては
、バレンシアのXX Proはありませんが、非常に素晴らしい紫色が得られます。
より目立つ仕様に
は、内陸の霧発生器と、
ビデオについて話すすべてのビデオの15秒の制限時間が含まれている
ため、カメラは
基本的に使用できませんが、ここにあります
フリップフォンを使って
実際のカメラを購入することで毎月の節約ができること私は35z4を1年半持っていた
ので先月パナソニックgh2を購入し、
残りを使っ
て韓国のフォトツアーに参加し
ましょう フォニックス35cからバッテリー寿命をオンにすることができるときにそれをまっすぐにカットして
くださいこの電話の画面時間は
最小限である
ため、実際には充電せずに文字通り何週間も行くことができます私は
ミリアンペアが何であるかわかりません
バッテリーの時間は健康で、
電話を充電します。充電コードを紛失し
たことがあります。ebayから新しいものを注文しました。
4日後、手に負えない
ビルド品質が完全に不足しているため、まだフル充電
でした。  eaturesと画像
解像度Picassoだけが
あなたがおそらくこの電話が安いと思っていることを認めることができました
、そして私は
あなたが1199のマルチコントラクトまたはプロ512メガバイトバージョンで無料で標準バージョンを手に入れることができるとあなたが正しいと報告することを嬉しく思います
少し急な$14.99で、
特に写真に興味がない場合は、
貯蓄をダウングレードし
てハイファイオーディオプレーヤーを購入でき
ます。サンハイザーのペアがスピードボートのトレーラーを貼り付け
ます。エチオピアの小さな家族にも食事を提供しています。
さらに、35 Zを使用すると、この電話で
強迫性/強迫性のアップグレード障害
を完全に忘れることができます。これまでのところ
、最新のテクノロジーアップグレードから切り離されており、
更新はフェラーリにとって無関係に
なり、ポルシェ愛好家
は0〜60で0.5秒が巨大になります。 ステーションワゴンの
所有者は、35 Zのバレルの底にいるほどではありませんが
、元の
iPhoneでさえメジャーアップグレード
になります。つまり、35zはゲームチェンジャー
です。
彼の元のiPhone基調講演の興味深いグラフが明らかになり、このデバイスが何であるかを正確
に説明するために、ここで再訪したいと思い
ます。
基調講演
はここではそれほどスマートではなく、トリオやブラックベリー
などの第1世代のスマートフォンを使用するのは簡単ではありません
ポールは間違いなくスマートですが、
実際には現在のスマートフォンを使用するのはさらに難しい
ですが、35はどこにありますか Zよく私は
あなたがここでそれを推測した元のiPhone以来の技術のすべての進歩を考慮して
いますが、
スクラップを回すと、フォニックス
を見ることができるように、毎日電話で費やされた時間の経過に伴う3番目のz軸の平均ユーザーウェイクボードレベルが明らかになりました
単にチャートから外れている
これは私の意見では、スマートフォンを35Zに交換する最良の理由は
1080pを裏側に交換する10人の
大丈夫です
下のコメントセクションで自由にチャット
してください。まだ
鼻をかむ練習をすることを忘れないでください。